hey guys i'm ryan right and 47 thousand
people have requested that i watched the
trailer for transformers 4 age of
extinction everyone is really excited
personally and I have already pissed off
a lot of people by saying this not a big
fan of the first 3 transformers I was a
little bored during part 1
I fell asleep in part 2 and 3 I don't
know if something about it just didn't
really interest me it's like the
trailers though are always so damn good
they are cinema at its best the trailers
are like orgasmic then I watched the
movie and I'm like this is kind of
boring but you know Mark Wahlberg's in
this one I like Marky Mark the idea of
Mark Wahlberg and Michael Bay pairing up
again after pain and gain is so
different from each other but it's Mark
Wahlberg Mark Wahlberg tends to be no
really [ __ ] cool no matter what he
does that's not sure he's done some
pretty horrible things
remember Max Payne broken city that
happening don't know what the hell was
happening there because I said that
happening what the hell is happening
there I guess I'm excited I just I feel
like I'm gonna get swayed against I feel
like I'm gonna love this trailer and
then I'm gonna be disappointed with the
movie but I'm gonna give it a chance
even if this trailer looks horrible I
will still watch it even though it's
directed by Michael Bay the most famous
most hated director on the planet let's
transform people it's transform it's
been approved good good
I do remember Chicago
bring it up all right damn is so buff
he's got the hottest daughter [ __ ]
like obey
he needs making some money yeah it's
relatable because he's a hard-working
struggling father I like it
I think we just found a transformer I
think we just found a transformer
Optimus Prime oh I give me killed
ouch
all right okay go that's pretty cool
yeah a new year I forgot the age of the
Transformers is over it's the age of
extinction
don't you get it we don't need you
anymore
Oh stanley tucci I love that guy
whoa
oh [ __ ]
ah [ __ ] it's like sucking up everything
it's parachuting
Oh
oh damn oh please don't disappoint me
movie IMAX okay go on IMAX er I heard
some of this was shot with IMAX cameras
so I'm going to be there obviously that
trailer [ __ ] rocked but those
transformers movies they didn't have the
same trailers like it's a very serious
epic dark tone and there ends up being
just like weird annoying comedy in them
but who knows I like this idea instead
of following chili buff around again or
LeBouf I like the idea of seeing a dad
who's you know it's a hard-working
struggling father that the buffest
father you'll ever see who based off his
job I don't I don't get why he's so cut
he's someone who seems a little bit more
likable a little bit more relatable so
that's a cool thing but [ __ ] Michael
Bay and it says his daughter is just
ridiculously hot granted it's Mark
Wahlberg's daughter so I'm sure she'd be
OTT but just choose someone who looks a
little bit more realistic for this
[ __ ] movie but the transformers
transformers look cool you know one day
they're gonna do a Transformers movie
where it's really about the Transformers
instead of trying to make about the
human being I think if they managed to
put some type of really cool focus on it
the Dinobots I think that's what they're
called or I just made that up I'm not
sure they look pretty [ __ ] sweet it's
like Jurassic Park meets transformers ah
Steven Spielberg produced it that's
probably why it looks so good but that
moment where they were like where is
Optimus Prime I was like yeah there's
gonna be a sick [ __ ] movie I don't
know something about the [ __ ]
Transformers whenever they come across a
human who happens to pick them up
randomly they're like you know what you
should chill with us for a while anyway
yeah well thanks check out my video see
that button watch click and subscribe
just subscribe will ya please it would
be nice for you to do that we can hang
out every week it'd be really cool Oh
before I forget there's a reason why I
decided to post this the following day
it's because one of the real rejects of
subscribers is a dude named Miles
Parkinson who I like to call Myles
Parkinson's disease it's his birthday
today I forgot your journey man I think
you're turning 22 23 anyway dude happy
[ __ ] birthday hope it's a good one
hope you get laid today hope you finally
get
for the first time in your life kidding
dude I'm sure you get a lot of poo Danny
yeah man happy birthday don't smoke too
much weed you don't want to you know go
high and drive no wait that's drinking
that's right drinking is the bad one for
you that's why marijuana is okay because
it's not as bad as